if you've only seen inception once
you've probably still got some questions
about how it all went down even if
you've seen it a hundred times you may
still be puzzling go for a thing or two
here are some of the biggest unanswered
questions in Inception when carbon is
crew first recruit Ariadne to be the
architect for the Fisher inception job
they have to begin to let her in on all
the various rules and procedures that
come with the field of dreams sharing
along the way they mentioned the history
of the dream sharing process it's why
the military developed dream sharing was
a training program for soldiers to shoot
established training each other
wake up from there the technology
eventually made his way to the private
sector in some form where it's now used
for criminal enterprises like extraction
and inception but given what we know
about dream sharing it's worth asking
how widespread is the use of this
technology
if high-end criminals are able to obtain
and use it and if CEOs around the world
know about it as a criminal practice
then what else's dreams sharing being
used for you mustn't be afraid to dream
a little bigger darling the inception
prequel comic sheds a little more light
on the idea of dream sharing being used
for entertainment purposes but the film
does not and the possibilities it would
seem are endless the Saito job at the
beginning of the film is a dream within
a dream extraction and this implied that
doubling up on dream wells like that is
both difficult and at least somewhat
rare within the world of dream sharing
for the later Fisher job Cobb decides
the crew needs to go even deeper and he
asked the three dream levels to achieve
this the crew turns to Yusuf who uses
powerful drugs to keep the dreamers
under for the duration of the job
there's a catch though when you're under
that deep you don't wake up when you
dive you descend into limbo Cobb and his
crew spend the rest of the film
navigating the difficulties of this
triple dreamworld and there proves
challenging for all of them but it also
raises an interesting question how many
layers could you conceivably build into
a dream the way the film is structured
suggests the idea of limbo as a kind of
bottom for the characters but how much
dream space could exist between this and
a third level if three layers isn't
enough to coax inception with a strong
subconscious could you go further Cobbs
not going to try anytime soon
but it's interesting to think about in
the Fischer inception job the first
level of the dream is a relatively
simple rainy cityscape within that
dreamworld a coven is corrupt to abduct
Fisher as he's catching a taxi then take
him to a warehouse and begin the process
of Inception they're interrupted in this
endeavor by armed men who are
projections of Fisher's subconscious
trying to fight them off of course
common compañía counting on that what
they didn't count on was a train
suddenly crashing through traffic and
disrupting their efforts so why does the
Train pop up well it's the same train
that Marlon Cobb used to kill themselves
what in limbo to take themselves up and
out of their dream state and in the
cityscape it basically leaps out of
Cobbs subconscious and into the dream
because his guilt is so invasive that it
can get in the way even when he's not
the dreamer or the subject but why is it
the train and nochmal possibly because
he knew mal was the more prominent
subconscious threat and was doing his
best to fight her a train at the symbol
of the moment he pulled me out of limbo
and thus doomed her was something he
wasn't necessarily counting on in the
beginning cobb is working overseas and
we slowly learn that it's not by choice
he's a wanted man in the United States
where he's been blamed for his wife's
death he sometimes causes children on
the phone and he even chances a trip to
Paris to pass along gifts for them via
his father but he can't go back home
until he finds a way to buy his way back
he takes the inception job but casino
offers him freedom after nothing but a
phone call while the film doesn't really
elaborates on is exactly how long Cobb
has been living this verse
of his life it ultimately doesn't matter
much to the story because the main
thrust of the plot is in the inception
job but since pass is particularly
important in the context of the ending
in the final scene a cop finally sees
his kids again and they appear to be
virtually unchanged from his last memory
of them so has he only been gone for a
few months or has he simply lost his
grip on reality if there's a reigning
king of unanswered questions hanging
over the mystery Laden inception it's
this what exactly is going on in the
final scene at the end of the film Sato
makes good on his promise and puts in a
call on Cobbs behalf Cobb goes through
customs in Los Angeles and goes home to
see his kids setting his totem to spin
on the kitchen table he leaves before he
can see if it falls or not and the film
cuts to black before the viewer can get
a definitive answer
so was Cobb still dreaming there are
some fans who would argue that he was as
evidence but a lack of aging in his
children and the possibility that he had
mulleted and wake up from limbo into
reality but instead into another layer
of a dream that he hasn't escaped from
the more optimistic idea here though is
not that cop ignores the top because he
no longer cares if he's dreaming but
rather because he no longer needs it to
know what's real the love he feels for
his kids in that moment it's so permeate
saying that he can't help but understand
that he's not dreaming the evidence for
this well the top does appear to be on
the verge of falling in those final
frames plenty of different
interpretations of the final scene exist
online many with compelling evidence to
back up their claims and that's exactly
how Christopher Nolan would have it the
writer director refuses to explain that
ending himself for a very good reason
speaking at the Tribeca Film Festival in
2015
Nolan explained that it once given a
very thorough explanation of the ending
to its previous films memento with the
caveat that it was only his
interpretation and not the definitive
answer later his brother and fellow
screenwriter Jonathan Nolan explained to
him nobody hears our first bit where you
say it's really up to the viewers if you
then give your interpretation though
that it realized his brother was right
saying it's the last time I ever opens
my mouth so there you have it there's no
definitive answer to the ending of
Inception because Christopher Nolan
really would in this case like you to
make up your own mind check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos by your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you